phát hiện địa điểm sắm Tết đầy đủ tất tần tật đồ Tết
từ đồ ăn bánh kẹo đồ giác dụng di di di di
tất cả đều có tại hội chợ này luôn nha mọi người ơi ồ ôi
sắp Tết rồi đấy mọi người ơi
nhà mình đã mua sắm gì chưa
cứ Tết đến ý là cái gì cũng phải sắm
mà thứ nhất là càng gần Tết ý
là càng không biết là phải sắm ở đâu Cho nó vừa đầy đủ
đỡ phải đi lại nhiều
sắm nhanh mà lại còn phải yên tâm nữa cơ
cơ mà cô ta vừa mới phát hiện Ra cái chỗ này mới
toanh lại còn siêu hay ho
luôn đầy đủ tất cả các tiêu chí sắm Tết luôn nha mọi người
chính là tuần lễ sản phẩm Thái Lan 2 02 6
Thái Lan quýt 2 02 6
ngày 2 2 đến 2 5 tháng một sắp tới mới diễn Ra
vẫn ở 91 Trần Hưng đạo Hà Nội nha
nhưng mà mọi người nhìn sự kiện từ trước hàng năm nó đông
dã man chưa
vì là ở đây có tới hơn 120 dân hàng với đủ thứ Cho mùa Tết
từ thực phẩm đồ uống Thái mua về biếu là quá hợp
đồ mẹ và bé an toàn rõ nguồn gốc
mỹ phẩm chăm sóc sức khỏe cũng siêu cần để làm đẹp
đón năm mới quần áo trang sức phụ kiện sang chảnh
thì không thể thiếu rồi đồ tác dụng đẹp
bền rẻ rồi cả sản phẩm chất thú cưng cũng có luôn nha
à không thể thiếu là các
tour du lịch VI vu Thái Lan dịp Tết này
ở đây cũng có rất rất nhiều
biết đâu đến đây lại chốt được vài BA kèo đi du lịch Thái
Lan đầu năm thì nó lại quá là ô kê la lá lô
nhở thề luôn cái hội chợ này nó lại
quá hợp Cho mỗi dịp cuối năm ý bảo SAO mọi người đi nhiều à
mà đương nhiên là không chỉ có mua sắm đâu
mà còn có nhiều chương trình khuyến mãi quà
tặng mỗi ngày nữa
và chắc chắn là còn được ăn thử ẩm thực
Thái chuẩn vị thái Xê lích luôn đó
cuối năm á lịch của AI cũng bận rộn ý
thì càng là nên đi một chỗ mà mua được tất cả trong một
như này nha lưu liền để 2
2 đến 2 5 tháng một với Thái Lan quýt 2 02 6 nha
đi là có đồ Tết mang về luôn đó